we know that access to birth control
reduces abortions it's very clear we
spoke to Jessica Pico about this
yesterday widely accepted by the
scientific and medical community so when
you increase access to birth control you
reduce abortions which is something that
right-wingers like right wingers should
be happy about increasing access to
birth control but generally they oppose
it that being said we've got pretty good
news from Colorado women in Colorado are
now able to buy birth control without
going to the doctor sort of like men can
do with condoms Colorado is joining
California and Oregon and allowing
pharmacists to prescribe oral
contraceptives commonly known as the
pill and I see a lot of people
expressing concern that oh these are
going to be handed and handed out like
candy with no medical oversight
whatsoever and if that's what you
believe you've not actually read how
this law works women are required to
first of all complete a questionnaire at
the pharmacy they have to get their
blood pressure checked and they have to
consult with a pharmacist before
actually getting the birth control pills
and pharmacists are going to be
additionally trained as well to know
what to screen for what to look for
which medications to give each woman
based on her particular situation and
this is going to reduce abortions this
has already been tested in Colorado and
it has led to a 42 percent decline in
teen pregnancy among the tested group
it's led to huge Medicaid savings as
well because hey childbirth is way more
expensive than birth control for every
dollar spent on this program five
dollars in Medicaid spending was saved
sort of shocking wright-patt pharmacists
prescribed birth control reduces
pregnancy and abortion and it saves
money it's fiscally conservative and it
aligns with socially conservative
priorities of abortion reduction and you
still don't get much Republican support
for it and this can save money for the
individuals as well because you know a
lot of people don't have access to
health care even in the Affordable Care
Act age and if you're if you don't have
to go to your primary care to get some
sort of permission before you go to the
pharmacist I mean that's one extra step
less to pay out of pocket it is yet
another area of savings and I was
thinking well
in what way doesn't this work for
right-wingers it violates the right wing
ideals of Christian sexual repression so
it's bad bad bad
there are ideologically religious
right-wingers who oppose abortion
because they believe there should be
punishment for extramarital recreational
sex ideological religious right-wingers
also sometimes don't really care about
preventing STDs because again STDs are a
just punishment for promiscuity or at a
more basic level extramarital
recreational non-procreative sex and
when you look at Colorado and then a
state like Texas these are perfect case
studies on the right and wrong way to
handle young people having sex texas
clothes reproductive health clinics
maternal death rate went way up
conservative policies are ineffective
and they get women killed liberal
policies on this issue save money they
save lives and they reduce abortions if
you're a politician at this point who
doesn't support measures such as this
you can't genuinely argue that you're
concerned about reducing the number of
abortions and let's also not forget just
as a sort of coda to this the impact of
real comprehensive sex education when it
comes to lowering abortion rates and
teen pregnancy but again right-wingers
also seem to oppose that today's episode
made possible by taga dab the hosting
specialist taga dab offers a range of
flexible hosting packages including
dedicated VPS and cloud server options
they also do custom server solutions and
colocation services taga dab has a
really user-friendly interface and
excellent customer support team their
expert hosting specialists also are
their friendly support team and they
give customers full access to their
knowledge and service with over 70% of
taga DAB's business coming from repeat
orders and recommendations and a
Trustpilot review rating of nine point
seven out of ten you know that taga dab
takes their customer service very very
seriously with a growing number of
people interested in moving their
businesses and
projects to the cloud taga dad is
offering you as a David Pakman show
viewer or listener a twenty British
Pound free credits about twenty four US
dollars to all new customers signing up
to give you a chance to try their
services to take advantage of it go to
sign up tagged adapt calm /td PS for
more information on their cloud VPS and
dedicated server features once again
sign up taga Deb comm slashed edps use
the discount code TDPS 20